[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
d
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant
[Musique]
régis labeaume
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
sommes très très heureux de vous
souhaiter la bienvenue sur l'a5 merci
d'avoir allumé votre téléviseur merci
d'avoir ouvert votre maison et nous
l'espérons votre coeur à la 5 l'a5 et
une nouvelle télévision une télévision
de spectacle plein d'optimisme de rythme
de lumière de joie une télévision pour
des loisirs sera et heureux l'a57 une
chaîne de plus donc une chance en plus
ce qui n'enlève rien aux autres bien au
contraire l'a5 c'est un choix
supplémentaire un choix qui existe là
maintenant depuis quelques secondes l'a5
est entièrement gratuite et financée par
la publicité la publicité qui serait
mise six minutes par heure ce qui veut
dire 10% de publicité et 90% de
spectacles des spectacles que nous
espérons toujours plus nous vos plus
beaux et plus passionnant l'a5 nous
l'espérons également deviendra votre
compagnon de tous les jours une
télévision a mis un rendez vous
quotidien mais un rendez-vous également
pour demain pour après demain et pour
toujours
nous ne sommes pas seuls sur l'a5 à part
les ballets de l'a5 a pas alors
qu'istres de l'a5 il y à déjà sur l'a51
équipage et comme toute équipe qui se
respecte et qui a envie de gagner avec
vous et bien cette équipe est composée
de onze joueurs onze amis mesdames
mesdemoiselles messieurs nous sommes
très heureux de vous présenter
maintenant les visages de la 5 l'équipe
de l'as saint etienne
j'ai loupé le journaliste le plus petit
poney 2 la cinq
capable de venir arrivée d'air chaud à
la place de vosges
antoine dernier a jusqu'à présent
dix ans me fera partager aux jeunes de
son âge
hubert auriol
bâle où il sera sur la scène celui qui
vous donnera chaque semaine de
spectacles de l'aide
guillaume durand le journaliste des
records et des événements sportifs avec
le grand show de la cie
richelle le vent l'eau
[Musique]
vous avez annoncé 11 personnes pour
l'équipe de l'a5 et nous sommes que dis
je crois que la personne qui manque
c'est une personne que je connais bien
que tu connais encore vieux que moi une
personne qui est très mystérieuse et
j'ai le sentiment qu'elle fera durer le
suspense et qu'elle n'arrivera que vers
le milieu de cette émis pour enfin
toujours est il qu'il n'y a pas que
l'équipe de la 5 ce soit il ya beaucoup
beaucoup d'invités qui sont des amis de
l'a5 qui sont vos amis des amis qui sont
venus sur la 5 ce soir vous souhaitez
nous souhaiter bonne chance et bon
voyage mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
ce soir sur l'a5 charles aznavour je
suis heureux de déclarer officiellement
ouvert la saq
comment
chanter vous voulez me faire chanter moi
dans ce soir au lion c'est un grand soir
deux premiers mais les gars vous dis une
chose monde que j'aime la scène et l'a5
johnny hallyday après avoir vécu la
grande aventure du rock'n'roll je suis
très heureux de participer à la grande
aventure de la 5 bonne chance à 5
nadia kaci ni suivi ici exprès tout dire
je t'aime la scène
ring on chausse à la 5
mai commissaire d'eric
la sen a toujours
un alibi
sylvie vartan aussi heureuse d'être une
des marraines de ce grand lancement
merci silvio et à l'envolée la 5
eros ramazzotti pas cinq restaurants
portable
céleste johnson and state wi fi co forex
les failles ou ugo tognazzi
[Musique]
la rigueur schwan présidente la métro
goldwin ben ça va cinq familles
de
france
[Musique]
henri salvador eh bien je suis très
heureux de participer aux premiers pas
de la 5
carmen
rousset soir j'ai dans le coeur la scène
jean luc lahaye chance à la secte
enjoint la fia lien le chiffre 5 est un
chiffre porte-bonheur alors mon cher
silvio 5 pour l'a5
propaganda
villa 5
patrick sébastien soir et bonne chance à
la 5 et surtout merci merci silvio pour
tout le plaisir qu'on va voir dans les
mois qui vont venir parce que moi je
sais qu'avec deux fois plus de qualité
qu'ailleurs et trois fois plus de belles
filles je me connais la 5 ça va être
super 5.2 aller 5 robert balma locle à 5
catherine malard me magique avec l'a5
richard clayderman je suis très heureux
de faire partie de la grande famille de
la 5
on est là multi jets message poteau mais
amoureux il faut que vous aimez la 5
rudolph nureyev bon sens à la 5
michel platini je suis très fier de
jouer ce soir ce terrain de la 5
michel berger et bien je suis très
heureux ce soir de faire partie de la
grande famille là la 5
serge gainsbourg
l'a5 c'est classieux
michel sardou tous les artistes voudrait
un début comme le tien bravo la 5 et
mireille mathieu je suis ravi de chanter
ce soir sur l'a5
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant remercier tous les artistes
qui vont participer à cette grande
soirée mais nous tenons également à
remercier tous les amis qui nous ont
soutenus tout ceux qui ont manifesté
leur sympathie temps par téléphone que
parlait peu que par télégramme que par
télex de france d'europe du monde entier
vraiment sincèrement de la part de la 5
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soir le monde de la télévision est en
fait plusieurs chaînes de télévision du
monde entier nous ont envoyé leurs voeux
est certaine nous les ont envoyées en
images
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on sait
je suis grise carole ainsi paul farmer
nous présentant le journal et le but
d'information du soir de signer ici de
notre ciel d'atlanta ont soigné la
nouvelle chaîne française l'a5 beaucoup
de chance et de succès
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à twilight cbs est
heureux de voir sa nouvelle série
paraître sur le premier émetteur privé
français de tous ici de twilight zone
joignant nos collègues de cbs castro
félicité la 5 et lui souhaiter plusieurs
années de succès chance
[Musique]
bonjour la 5e je m'appelle chine et hong
kong des crimes de la kb s ayant appris
la naissance de votre station de
télévision je suis très heureuse de vous
adresser au nom de 8000 personnes de ma
société un message de félicitations
[Applaudissements]
bonjour tout le monde et salue tous les
téléspecteurs françaises et français
j'suis pas existe et spécialement mes
amis jérôme seydoux silvio berlusconi et
la nouvelle chine cinq nouveaux chouette
tous les artistes ou les techniciens
dove télévision vous souhaite un grand
succès avec la nouvelle chine cinq
salles où vivent là ça inc
[Musique]
l'arrêt du globo de télévision du brésil
salut lassant les premiers réseaux de
télévision vers privé de la france
en lui souhaitant les plus grands se
sait et qui sont l'exemple soit un
encouragement pour tous les groupes
voilà un mix racing au centre-ville aux
études et éviterait télévision de
catalogne mes très chers amis de la
scène ont reçu la viande veut ni à
travers des maîtresses la télévision
autonomic de la catalogne vous êtes au
premier jour de mission
et nous croyons que la meilleure façon
de commencer notre amitié c'est en vous
offrant notre plusieurs souris voilà
[Musique]
à
l'occasion de sa première journée de
télédiffusion les nouvelles et les
informations sont importants pour tout
le monde dont tous les faits et l'a5
représente encore une autre source de
télévision dans un des pays le plus
important de ligue europe du fait que le
5 et le premier réseau commercial et
indépendant de la france la diffusion
des nouvelles et des informations par
l'a5 est encore plus important vers
à tous ces messages que nos amis
d'antenne 2 nous ont envoyé un très
gentil fait les g que se défaire 3 nous
ont fait parvenir un texte fort
sympathique et que nos amis de canal +
viennent de nous envoyer une carte de
visite très gentil dé tf1 dès faria du
tout commenté a fait rien du tout ne
fassiez pas possible et au et et moi
qu'est ce qu'il fait là
[Applaudissements]
seuls à descendre l'escalier sans
regarder mes piles ça c'est vrai c'est
vrai que c'est une permanente cenap et
bien tombé et sans tomber mes bouteilles
hervé bourges m'a délégué pour présenter
à la 5 ses meilleurs voeux voilà à
gentilly s'est séparé sans vous faites
tous les deux pour les deux papillons
qui tiennent droit comme ça j'ai tué ma
vie j'ai ya en lui donne bien trop tôt
ce matin le dire tu pourras lourd et de
l'adhésif double côté ah c'est pas bête
c'est comme ça derrière franchitti truc
eux j'ai un petit cadeau pour vous ces
cartes et les fans en plus tellement de
moyens mais hervé bourges a tenu à
confectionner lui-même un gâteau il ya
passé tout le week-end ce sera le gâteau
qui fêtera la naissance de la sag il
n'est pas présentée par n'importe qui
regardez
karim
[Musique]
m
et
en chirurgie mon cher christian merriot
je vais te débarrasser allez merci c4 à
l'eau
et aux
attentes et on s'assied et comptera pour
la saq mais on rentre le mouscron la
mouvance ont la pression mais mon
rentrant la piste ranger rentrer tout de
suite la paix sont à
[Applaudissements]
mon avis de chacun d'abord si vous
saviez ce que ça coûte quoi les moyens
mais est en plus une belle amitié virile
comme ça fait pas beaucoup tous les deux
allez il a peut-être pas tort oui oui
mais enfin nous comme ça maintenant on
se retrouve sans rien et si christian on
a invité un invité très important encore
ah mais oui effectivement et oui
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs pour
la première fois sur l'a5 la publicité
si votre première page de publicité sur
les 5 ouais bah j'espère beaucoup que ça
peut être la dernière
voilà c'était la première page de
publicité belle et bref comme vous
l'avez vu la 5 tient toujours ses
promesses et va vous offrir de très très
beau programme derrière nous la grille
de ses programmes justement 28 écran 4
par jour un pour chaque heure d'émission
et comme il faut une logique à toute
chose les programmes démarre le lundi et
le lundi sur l'a5 que ça débute à 19h30
avec une émission distrayante excitante
amusante une émission de jeu c'est beau
la vie présentée par alain gillot-pétré
[Musique]
alain très grande responsabilité
c'est vous qui allez ouvrir la grille de
l'a5
non nous en responsabilité pénale
responsabilités parce que figurez vous
que c'est quand même énorme production m
tous les lundis et mardis les mercredis
les jeudis et les vendredis de 19h30 à
20h30 c'est beau la vie animée par moi
même alors vous allez me dire qu'est ce
que c'est que ces bollène miens c'est
une émission veut très distrayante il l
a dit très amusante et va le dire aussi
c'est pas un problème ça consiste en
quoi c'est basé sur des enquêtes
d'opinion votre opinion d'ailleurs vous
répéterai tout ça lors de la première
émission vous avez qu à regarder demain
c'est pas un problème non plus des
enquêtes d'opinion des enfants des
femmes des enfants des vieux des jeunes
des dessins des maris des femmes mariées
avec poisson rouge sans poisson rouge
tout ce que vous voulez c'est une très
bonne émission je peux vous le dire
parce que c'est pas moi qui les crée je
vous fais simplement le plaisir de vous
la présenter et c'est donc tous les
jours sur la cinq avec ça vous pourrez
vous faire et là je deviens un peu
sérieux vous pourrez vous faire un auto
portrait de ce que vous êtes de ce
qu'ils sont de ce que nous sommes de ce
que je suis
vous allez voir maintenant les premières
images de la cinq et avec alain
gillot-pétré une chose est certaine
c'est qu'avec vous alain prévost les
tous les jours vous avez rendez vous
avec c'est beau la vie du lundi au
vendredi à 19h30 sur la saq
c'est beau la vie vous attend avec un
beau temps animée par alain gillot-pétré
du lundi au vendredi à 19h30 c'est beau
la vie un jeu un d'armé traduisant qui
vous fera connaître les opinions les
préférences des français
c'est beau la vie tous les jours du
lundi au vendredi à 19h30 sur l'a5 votre
nouvel ami
pierrot dès samedi soir la température
continue de monter sur l'a5 c'est la
fièvre sur l'a5 avec miné car le che
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci ravi de vous recevoir à merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup mais je suis
vraiment de soleil parce que c'est
dommage mais je ne parle pas bien
français t vous parler suffisamment bien
pour que nous vous comprenons et de
toute manière votre présence niches non
mais je voudrais dit beaucoup de choses
je voudrais dire que je suis
comment tu te rends français amo siona a
tant ému a eu lieu je suis ému et et
géant quotité le trac et g
ça me dans mais les fruits sans bruit
sans penser qu'on prend et parce que
j'aime beaucoup les hommes je peux
comprendre et blais qui sont rêches à
main a qui ont du rythme
et wii est qu'ils sont tous morts de
faim je verrai et jean trop tard ah il
est magnifique il est et les charmants
il est super 2000 et mikhail et unique
jean prat volta il est unique non il
faut unique le roi
[Musique]
non non non oh non non non bravo bravo
je me suis arrêtée juste à la première
leçon et je vais pas rentrer chambre
c'est pas mon genre non non vous c'est
que vous êtes différent vous vous mettez
par contre comme je te vos stars non on
s'est trop même si c'est très classe et
vous à saigner bourse de casablanca les
films très célèbre gazaouis bogard et
oui et très classe et fraîchement lancé
c'est le genre oui et stable aux bye la
chanson oui super c'est pour vous oh
mercy casablanca
mais lee quarles o'shea
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
ce
même le ps
qu'elle sait ce geste pied
ça
je suis 2
je veux
[Musique]
s
m
testée c
1 et hugues et me
[Musique]
oui
never le pays
un chien je
[Musique]
m
c'est lui
key
et sinon
le
et
[Musique]
allez
elle sera
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
d
je viens
thomas et tu es
m
[Musique]
et
nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après la cinquième dimension nous
entrons maintenant dans une dimension
que nous n'avions pas encore exploré la
dimension du rock'n'roll avec un
monsieur johnny halliday
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dès monaco
c'est clairement la barre à gatineau
voilà la
machine à billy carlucci à québec il est
quand même très embêtant vous ne parlez
pas du tout italien
alitalia
non
non non je parle pas du tout français ça
commence bien on régime montant là david
si on pouvait me faire amener un
quelqu'un pour traduire s'il vous plaît
ouais merci merci beaucoup c'est ea sono
molto figé des cathares et cui aidé par
l'atce
johnny hallyday redit qu'il est très
fier et très heureux de chanter
aujourd'hui sur l'a5 et une âme et
améliore ses photographies à
que la la lumière est très joli sur ce
gallard nabet lalouch est
une très belle lumière et une très belle
photographie oui c'est sa
moto les gammes des présentateurs et
martha jane tirer
un présentateur très élégant et très
gentil oui et voudrait comme tard et à
mieux comme ça on est là tout et il
voudrait chanter une chanson pour tout
le monde et voudrait la cantarelle
italiana fille et il voudrait chanter et
annoncer cette chanson en italien est
possible
si merci quelque chose de tennessy
johnny hallyday
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il faut que je m'impose et son retrait
pendant vous pousse vers l'est
c' est maintenant très légère
on a tous quelque chose en nous de
tennessee
cette volonté de prolonger la nuit
ce désir fou de vivre une autre vie
ce rêve on ouvre avec ses mots à lui
est lé plus chaud
le tennessee
cette force qui nous faire l'infini
et à peu d'amour avec tellement dormi
si peu d'amour avec tellement de bruit
une chose en nous de tennessee
[Musique]
sidibé elle est si
le coeur enfiévré le corps des volets
avec cette formidable envie
il serait bon nous cette saison cris à
lui
quelques jours tdc
tous
[Musique]
toi qui s'est éteint dans la nuit
à
l'heure où
11ème à la folie
et
un écrin de voix et 101
en vain
lamy
à
il disparut
[Musique]
certes l e de la nuit
quand le coeur de la ville s'est endormi
il flotte un sentiment comme une envie
ni se rêve en nous avec ses mots à lui
quelque chose de tennessee
[Musique]
quelque chose
quelque chose on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
6 sur la fin que le lundi est super star
le mardi lui est entièrement consacré à
l'aventuré au fantastique mais voyons
tout d'abord comme d'habitude ce que
nous réserve alain gillot-pétré dans
c'est beau la vie
[Applaudissements]
à ces démissions des malvoyants
nous accueillons maintenant une artiste
qui n'était pas revenu en france depuis
le feuilleton les beaux quartiers de
aragon voici nadia kaci mai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir mabiala diète une star aux
etats-unis shocker danseuse chanteuse
mais elle a aussi une réputation due à
son charme et à sa séduction n'est ce
pas nadia nom christian surtout je suis
très célèbre pour rang des fous du moins
tous les présentateurs de la télévision
sur désirs ma femme bonsoir chérie
ça va vous vous sentez bien devient très
bien je veux parler de la soirée
fantastique j'ai l'impressionnait cause
or ce cas je n'aurais jamais pensé de
gaulle tournée en france dans une
occasion pareille vous avez apporté un
petit cadeau pour la 5 non non c'est la
5e m'a fait un merveilleux cadeau il me
donnait la possibilité de réaliser un de
plus beau de plus fantastique de plus
merveilleuse ballet que je fais dans ma
vie c'est exact en voici la preuve
deux trois quatre fois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci je vous pensais faire beaucoup
mieux que ça on a bien mieux que ça ou
peut-être
fait beaucoup enfin c'est le public qui
va juger de toute façon voici maintenant
nadia kaci ni dans son balai alléluia
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
et
e
à
ah ah
[Musique]
et
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous accueillons maintenant une très
grande star de la chanson voici michel
sardou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais que tu nous parles de tes
origines italiennes c'est vrai oui c'est
vrai mais enfin c'est très très vieux tu
sais ça remonte au moins à caligula
rapproche un peu oui ça faire une
tranche de vie c'est à dire qu'en fait
du côté de ma mère quelque part il ya eu
un homme assez célèbre qui a passé le
rubicon mais dans l'autre sens à
d'accord tu vois se dévoile et puis il a
disparu bien alors je suppose que tu
nous as apporté un petit cadeau pour le
5 bah je vais lui souhaiter la bienvenue
à 7,5 et puis comme cadeau je vais te
faire un petit compliment en italien en
italie ouais et puis ce petit compliment
je vais l'adresser à notre président de
la république
[Applaudissements]
ce que le président et doit être assis
sur son fauteuil devant sa télé comme
vous tous ce soir parce qu'il faut bien
le reconnaître finalement c'est lui qui
l'a voulu cette cinquième chaîne i s'est
battu pour l'avoir pour l'imposer c'est
pas facile tu sais même quand on est
quand on est président de la république
d'imposer une cinquième chaîne tu en as
entendu parler peut-être et puis ce soir
quelle leçon pour notre cohabitation
future puisque vous avez remarqué
mesdames et messieurs depuis le début de
cette émission et jusqu'à la fin et dieu
sait si elles durent longtemps à part
catherine lara et encore c'est pas sûr
il n'y a absolument aucun chanteur de
gauche merci monsieur le président de la
république alors c'est qu'il ya une
chose qui me frappe beaucoup c'est
extraordinaire mais tu n'as pas perdus
accent italien pas du tout pardon je dis
tu n'as pas perdu l'accent italien
excuse moi je ne parle pas du tout
français
mesdames et messieurs voici michel
sardou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me souviens d'une chanson
et de deux anneaux d'or que nous portons
encore et d'un petit garçon
je ne me souviens pas bien
qui de nous deux partaient et la mort de
mon chien
[Musique]
quelques années plus tard
on apprenait un soir
qu'un chêne été brisée qui l'avait pas
plié qu'il entrait dans l'histoire
[Musique]
1900 juste à faire
jeu
vient très bien
la couleur des volets les parfums du
jardin
[Musique]
l'innocence
viens d'avril
une femme aux yeux elle a voyagé
mais
difficile
c'est la première fissure
l'avocat
et les lettres d'agir
c'est la mort de mon père
et cette impression folle que ses
dernières paroles n'étaient pas les
dernières
et les années qui suivent
c'est la fuite en avant
bombarder l'iran des plus fortes qui
survivent
c'est la fin
[Musique]
d'une vie
sega
et j'oublie
[Musique]
je me souviens d'une chanson
et de deux anneaux d'or que nous portons
encore et d'un petit garçon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après michel sardou l'homme qui réussit
laventure dans la vie comme dans le
monde du spectacle
jonathan jonathan c'est votre rendez
vous du mardi soir avec l'aventuré avec
la nature jonathan c'est une émission
riche d'émotions riche de surprises et
riche d'image et les bonnes images
parlent souvent d'elle-même jonathan
c'est votre rendez vous du mardi soir à
22h30 avec olivier de kersauson sur l'a5
[Applaudissements]
jaune automne le rendez vous
hebdomadaire avec l' aventure et la
nature réalisés par les équipes de la
sainte dans les endroits les plus
étonnants du monde ceux où le droit de
savourer la beauté de ce camp caire qu'à
force de courage d'ardeur et de
sacrifices
jonathan et les spectacles pour ceux qui
veulent voler toujours plus haut pour
ceux qui veulent se mesurer avec les
difficultés toujours plus grande un
exemple pour les jeunes une leçon de
courage pour tous
[Musique]
maintenant nous allons aller au
venezuela dans le nord de l'amérique du
sud en pays tropical humide ici pour que
pour accompagner une expédition anglaise
qui est allé pour faire le la proche et
l' escalade des cascades les plus hautes
du monde appelait le saut angèle un
italien cependant a découvert qu'il y
avait des cascades plus haute et il en a
ramené les photos que vous allez voir
mais ses cascades n'ont pas encore
exactement mesure et on pense que la
cascade la plus haute du monde n'est pas
la cascade la plus haut et jonathan a
suivi la gendarmerie française les
hélicoptères pendant près de trente
sauvetage de 30 interventions en
intervention qui démontre à chaque fois
à quel point le métier de gendarmes de
haute montagne est un joli métier d'
aventure de technique et de risques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sous
respect
[Musique]
oh
si jamais ça
mais et
non
[Musique]
sacha
chez eux
[Musique]
à
mon passé
je suis là
g
[Musique]
m
s
[Musique]
l'espoir à ça
mais là
[Musique]
ça
mais
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ici à la 5 le mercredi nous offre sur le
cadeau du plaisir subtil de l'intriguent
passion sans limite un policier un petit
peu flegmatique infaillible des scoops
fantastique enfin du jamais vu en france
mais met le mercredi ne serait pas le
mercredi du tout s'il n'y avait pas bien
sûr gillot-pétré qu'il inaugure avec
c'est beau la vie
[Applaudissements]
y est depuis les prévisions météo de la
sec n'était pas allé plus fiables du
monde c'est une lamentable et triste
calomnie en effet non seulement elles
sont exactes mais en plus au goût du
public
photo e allô oui madame météo 5 oui
madame à m'écouter nous avons du soleil
à 25 contre 1 des nuages à 12 contre 1
de la pluie à deux contre un et de la
neige à 0 contre un
os moi si j'étais vous je prendrais
plutôt le soleil vu le temps qu'il fait
ce pas un problème oui madame 50 francs
un peu plus madame ne soyez pas radine
2000 francs mais bien entendu madame
c'est noté pas de problème 2000 francs
du soleil à 25 contre 1 une bonne
affaire absolument oui madame or madame
elle a passé sur une autre chaîne mais
tant pis c'est beau la vie quand même
[Applaudissements]
intrigue les hypocrisies et les amours
de flamingo road nous allons renvoyer la
balle maintenant un bon inspecteur de
police pour savoir comment lui résoudre
ses propres problèmes
voici maintenant l'inspecteur derrick
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j kidd gimone pour le sourire il cherche
à battre
l'inspecteur derrick un problème ils
demandent déjà si je ne connais
quelqu'un de la police française
pourquoi
ce gaz est l'une des races
traduction l'inspecteur a pris un pv
devant la porte il était garé en double
file devant la porte et il a pris un pv
c'est assez extraordinaire quand même un
inspecteur de police qui prend un pv non
nous ne cessons de sécheresse que
yannick ce mal bouffe comme brad pitt
alors traduction l'inspecteur n'est pas
dans sa juridiction est ce qui prouve
bien que même un inspecteur de police ça
peut prendre un pv voilà
inspecteur est ce que vous êtes un
policier cynique comme qu'à la gamme par
exemple
nous est désormais créer
d'inspecteurs se considère lui plutôt
comme à
un inspecteur maigret neveu nommé grêle
neveu allemand de l'inspecteur maigret
quel est votre plus grand succès aux
démarches reculé de benchenane souligne
martin and changes agyness deyn de
candice mix ou d'oubli pneus comme nine
spector au groupe a dont nantes on a le
plus grand succès la plus belle
arrestation de l'inspecteur derrick
c'est d'avoir passé les menottes au
succès c'est sa plus belle arrestation
et il le trouve puisque sur les sondages
de toutes les télévisions et bien on
s'aperçoit que l'inspecteur derrick et
l'inspecteur le plus aimé d'europe
[Musique]
un jeune chanteur est entré il n'y a pas
si longtemps dans tous les paradis
européen il nous arrive tout auréolé du
festival de la chanson de san remo je
vous demande d'applaudir maintenant et
re à l'agefi
[Musique]
dimas
là
[Musique]
à
10 h
[Musique]
m
c
je ici
[Musique]
c'est pas ça
h
[Musique]
pas du tout
et
oui
[Musique]
ellos ramazzotti qui avait fait un bon
succès chez nous avec una storia
importante est justement à propos d'
histoire importante et bien il ya la
science avec ses secrets avec ses
mystères et sur l'a5 l'homme qui a la
clé pour les résoudre c'est alexandre
balou qui vous fixent rendez vous le
mercredi à 22h30 avec big bang alexandre
balle ou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
merci nous allons parler du programme
mais j'aime à une petite explication sur
le titre de ce rendez vous le mercredi
big bang pourquoi bien big bang c'est
très simple c'est le nom donné par les
savants à l'hypothèse qui est la plus
couramment admise de nos jours pour
expliquer la naissance de l'univers
c'est à dire pas seulement de la terre
et de l'univers tout entier c'est en
quelque sorte l'explosion initiale c'est
une formidable concentration d'énergie
qui explosent et dont le développement
la diversification donne naissance à
tout ce qui fait notre monde notre
univers l'espace le temps aussi car tout
était confondu le minéral le végétal la
vie animale et par conséquent l'homme
alors ça ne va pas être trop trop
ennuyeux ce genre d'émission est bien
dit comme je viens de le dire
effectivement pourrait craindre que ce
soit ennuyeux mais ça ne le sera pas
pour deux raisons d'abord parce que nous
pratiquerons dans big bang un style qui
ne sera ni didactique ni pédant mais qui
sera direct simple chaleureux et puis
deuxièmement et surtout nous aurons des
documents absolument extraordinaire à
vous montrer je crois christian que le
meilleur moyen de convaincre les
téléspectateurs de la 5 c'est de leur
parler de deux documents que j'ai
visionné cet après midi le premier
montre des images absolument
extraordinaire de diane fossey diane
fossey vous la connaissez tous
téléspectateurs français la connaissent
on a beaucoup parlé d'elle en décembre
quand elle a été tout au rwanda alors
qu'elle se familiarise est depuis
maintenant quinze à vingt ans avec ses
gorilles et on verra comment diane
fossey a pu approcher les gorilles les
apprivoiser dialoguer avec eux en
quelque sorte bien autres documents qui
m'a beaucoup frappé aussi dans tout ce
que j'ai visionné c'est celui que
j'appellerais l'autopsié du pharaon
toutankhamon sa momie toutankhamon morts
à 18 ans grâce au mariage de la caméra
et de la radiographie nous allons dans
big bang faire un voyage à l'intérieur
de la momie de toutankhamon et ainsi
pouvoir peut-être mieux comprendre les
mystères de sa mort qui sont toujours
pas éclaircies puis des documents
christian il y en a beaucoup d'autres et
je veux dire qu'ils sont tous
extraordinaires rendez-vous lobbying
bien alors rendez vous tous les
mercredis à 22h30 avec alexandre balou
et laissons parler les images maintenant
sur cette présentation de big bang
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
big bang c'est le rendez vous
hebdomadaire avec le monde fantastique
de la science tous les mercredis à 22h30
soit la 5 votre nouvel ami
[Musique]
bienvenue sur l'a5 je m'appelle
alexandre balou et je vais tous les
mercredis soirs vous présenter une
émission qui s'appelle big bang le
spectacle de la vie le sous titre vous
en dit peut-être plus que le titre big
bang
[Musique]
le spectacle continue sur l'a5 si je
vous dis qu'elle est blonde qu'elle
danse divinement qu'elle chante
merveilleusement et que de panne
d'essence à one shot lover elle a
toujours su nous ravir vous devez me
répondre sylvie vartan
[Musique]
s'il dit je considère réellement que
vous à voir ce soir c'est un événement
non mais c'est tout à fait normal je
suis ravi d'être là ce soir c'est une
soirée d'inauguration vous me direz
c'est normal pour un artiste de faire de
la télévision mais de voir naître la
télévision une nouvelle télévision c'est
tout à fait exceptionnel je suis ravi
d'être vous sentez comment l'atmosphère
de ces je trouve que c'est très
sympathique c'est décontracté moi j'ai
vraiment envie de faire quelque chose
pour vous par exemple je pars je
pourrais être la première speakerine la
st
on n'ose pas en espérer autant mais si
vous voulez moi je veux bien vous
prendre au mot il ya aucun problème
il me faudrait peut-être pas une chèvre
il suffit de demander voilà il ya des
choses partout ici merci poursuites
merci beaucoup eh bien vous avez
un plan américain sur l'américain ce
qu'on peut faire un plan américain sur
ce il dit comme ça merci et puis le
texte
jusqu'à moi par exemple qui mesdames et
messieurs bonsoir mesdames et messieurs
bonsoir vous êtes bienvenu sur la cinq
soirées que c'est une soirée
exceptionnelle aujourd'hui la sauce ou
là c'est sous le signe du charme et la
beauté du souffle du sourire ce sourire
et ses sourires c'est celui de sylvie
vartan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en défense
m
[Musique]
dans deux jours ci
sa venue
[Musique]
tél
key
m
com
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tirant dessus
shop
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quel s
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
je
[Musique]
moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est que j'ai
non
j'accrochais
ciao
[Applaudissements]
qui
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et voilà le jeudi alors chez nous à l'a5
le jeudi et placée sous le signe de la
chance avec des prix très important et
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de charme mais mais comme
toujours l'honneur d'ouvrir la grille
des programmes revient au sémillant au
pétillant au merveilleux c'est beau la
vie avec alain gillot-pétré
[Applaudissements]
grave nouvelles on apprend de source
sûre qu'un troll et mentaires serait sur
le point de se déclencher le problème
c'est qu'on ne sait pas
exactement
où qu'il se
produira ses voix la vie quand même
l'important n'est pas de gagner mais de
participer et si monsieur de coubertin
tête avec nous de deviner où il serait à
pentathlon une compétition sur
l'intuition l'intelligence l'information
et la culture le tout mené par mon ami
roger zabel
c'est très très chic roger qu'est ce que
c'est que maintenant et bien pas patron
comme son nom l'indiqué c'est une
émission de jeu qui comporte cinq
épreuves cinq épreuves qui ont un
rapport direct avec l'actualité c'est le
spectacle de l'information cinq épreuves
à l'issue desquelles vous allez pouvoir
gagner beaucoup d'argent des voitures
des maisons et des tas d'état d'état des
tas d'autres choses et pour gagner à
pentathlon qu'est ce qu'il faut et bien
il faut bien suivre l'actualité avoir de
la chance mais aussi un minimum de
culture est votre premier rendez vous
avec pentathlon exceptionnellement
raison de la soirée de gala d'ouverture
de l'a5 ses deux mains vendredi à 20h30
avec trois invités exceptionnels jugez
plutôt evelyne bouix alain souchon et
lino ventura et je serai accompagné
d'elisabeth tordjman et de josé luis
moreno
[Musique]
merci si soyez le bienvenu bienvenu
merci pour tout et ouais
et rien derrière
ouais je ne regrette rien
salez
tu peux dire quelque chose de plus nos
mots aya tories on autorise date ce
thème il allie quest ix holidays in
tiennent tellement à nîmes between
tu peux par le français qu à faire
parce que nous on est dans une
télévision française laquelle la cenco
c'est une tradition française oui bien
sûr et aussi les spaghettis et la coca
cola
rockefeller je te dis qu'il n'y a pas
des spaghettis coca cola la 500c quoi
c'est le champagne ce des escargots
c'est du champagne c'est les ans oui
alors il faut parler français d'accord
être ou ne pas être ça sert à la
question de notre télévision tient
télévision spaghettis
remplacer les femmes prises la première
fois qu'on fait cette soirée je t'en
prie il faut que tu composes comme il
faut oui bien sûr pourquoi pas
qu'est ce que c'est toucher bordel que
vous avez fait j
en clair je t'en prie de quoi je parle
différemment je te le dis c'est laid
l'a1 le gala de présentation des quads
et l'a5 en france
comment est-ce que je m'en fous de tout
ça moi
et toi qu'est ce que tu fous là
je fais pas pu le spectacle
qui t'a fait stone easy
mon habileté pour faire à bouger quelque
et stupide marionnettes
tu parles de ta soeur non je parle en
général alors tu as la ville tenait à
faire bouger quelques marionnettes ben
oui si vous prêtez d'éduquer à la
politique majeure non parce que je suis
complètement politique aux
essais contagieuse à j'espère bien parce
que notre aux politiciens au café
librairie en syrie en france en
philosophie
[Musique]
alors messieurs dames brocarder la
seigne que oui oui oui et presque tout
le plus grosses vedettes oui de
l'actualité oui sont invités ce soir ici
est alors toi
je te dis que je suis artiste au
et à toi qui tapissent tourner ici mon
avis l'été à faire bouger quelques
crétins batterie l'eau
mais comme il est construit au café leur
kit appris à parler comme ça coluche
toi tu ne m était fabriqué par le
français comme une vache espagnole et
c'est la dernière fois que tu viens ici
je t'assure a rich man sur
quel est ton boulot ici je te le dis
tout à l'heure artiste spécialité
ventriloque et qu'est ce que c'est ça un
ventriloque c'est quelqu'un qui a la
faculté de parler avec l'estomac
dégueulasse
et berlusconi le césar mais
ça l'est la terre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors celle de vos frais salé ventrella
ton nom c'est au café l'air ces deux
numéros méricain oui tu américano merci
dites moi une chose qu'est ce que tu
attends de l'a5
rien un peu du travail - jusqu'à la
sélection et toi qu'est ce que tu
attends de la scène
moi je tenterai en communication avec un
des pays qui ont fait l'histoire et la
culture du monde
bien moreno à de la terre
rien d'autre
tu m'as dit que tu y as temps de travail
jusqu'à la sélection oui et comme si
comme tout était impossible de ce soir
c'est le moment de dire bonsoir acquis
aux téléspectateurs au cas parce qu'on
se retrouvera tous les jeudis à penne
qu'applaudir concentrera tous les jeudis
bien sûr il a fait faire de la reynière
de la cinq mois nos mains tout cargo
fait leurs fruits on est dans la même
galère si je m'en veux tu te va non
parce que j'ai écouté très attentivement
tous les discours de monsieur chirac et
il n'a jamais rien dit contre le corbeau
alors fait darmon et non c'est toi qui
dois faire attention je serai salle
toujours ici à là c'est pourquoi parce
que l'a5 sert le divertissement c'est la
tradition européenne
c'est la formation les sports
l'enlisement et surtout la simple c'est
moi
[Musique]
alors maintenant que nous avons vu josé
luis moreno nous allons voir les images
de patates l'eau
[Musique]
et n'oubliez pas tous les jeudis soirs
je vous attends à 20h30 sur à 5
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du firmament du cinéma une star est
tombé sur l'a5 mesdames et messieurs
ornella mutti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir on est là bon ça christian c'est
à dire que quand on se trouve côté d'une
femme comme vous
sait plus trop quoi dire mais voulait
macapa 17 et venant
j'aimerai vous voir la place quoi ils
veulent tous être à ma place mais s'ils
semblent très surpris par votre français
moi aussi
j'ai une question indiscrète à vous
poser en est là
voilà vous avez tourné avec les plus
grandes stars françaises alain delon
gérard depardieu que les celui des deux
qui embrasse le mieux mais c'est moi qui
menace les miens
mais j'aurais tout donné pour être à
leur place oui tout mais ça c'est pas un
problème à la sainteté possible un peu
l'atmosphère romantique de la musique
je ne peux pas vivre sans toi
tu madame x
j'étais
[Musique]
la scène
je crois que cette façon d'embrasser va
être très très salll à dams et messieurs
or des larmes août
vous avez un spectacle c'est un peu
comme un puzzle s'est fait de différents
morceaux il suffit de les rassembler
pour que ça fasse une très très belle
image et pour continuer à fabriquer
cette très belle image de la 5 nous
avons maintenant une pièce a rajouté au
puzzle une pièce très important d'une
pièce très très belle qui n'est autre
que mireille mathieu
[Applaudissements]
questionnaire j'ai apporté un cadeau
pour un nouveau-né mais je crois que
j'ai pas fait le bon choix mais pourquoi
cette ré midouze oui assez mignon c'est
vrai mais je croyais que la scène qui
était une chaîne naissante et je me suis
aperçue qu'elle était adulte et qu'elle
l'ait devenir une très grande chaîne
alors j'ai choisi un présent plus
approprié
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et après cette courte page publicitaire
nous nous retrouvons devant notre grille
pour voir ce que nous réserve le
vendredi nous avons trouvé une formule
irréfutable un peude intrigue beaucoup
de mystères et une pointe de vitesse
celles de alain gillot-pétré et de ces
sondages c'est beau la vie à 19h30
[Applaudissements]
c'est beau la vie nous apprenons avec
une joie non dissimulée le lancement
réussi du satellite de
télécommunications mondiales silvio
premier il a en effet été mis sur orbite
ce matin avec succès vous pourrez ainsi
demain regardez nos programmes dans
toute l'europe avec en prime les
prévisions météorologiques
rectification contentez-vous d'écouter
la radio
doute la plus grande surprise de cette
soirée nous ne l'attendions pas mais il
a tenu à venir mesdames messieurs je
vous demande de faire une ovation à
monsieur jacques chirac
[Applaudissements]
compagnon
ce n'est pas en tant que maire de paris
michel rpr que je me présente ce soir
mais en tant qu imitateur de patrick
sébastien j'aimerais ce soir souhaiter
bienvenue à la 5 et pour ça j'ai préparé
un discours que je vais vous lire dans
plusieurs langues puisque la chaîne aura
peut-être une vocation européenne et
j'ai donc fait traduire ce discours par
des employés de la mairie de paris c'est
à dire des corréziens c'est un anglais
de brive la gaillarde que vous allez
entendre d'abord en anglais mesdames
mesdemoiselles messieurs les dix morosi
gentleman
pour moi être sur l'a5 for me to bien 5
c'est une satisfaction heineken gettnau
je ne suis pas
je ne suis pas le roi de france
évidemment il ya menottes god save the
queen mais je suis en quelque sorte son
dauphin haye a misé flipper j'aimerais
exprimer également en espagnol mesdames
et messieurs seniors et señorita les
fans espagnols sont de belles plantes et
sa seigneurie table salade
en arabe j'aimerais vous dire qu'en
france on n'a pas de pétrole mais on a
des idées est un one man
rakoff de l'avant en italien j'aimerais
vous dire que je suis content parce
qu'il fait chaud en italie est au
qualifié italien alors qu'on gèle à
paris angelo parisi
j'aimerais reprendre mon anglais
maintenant pour vous dire que je suis
votre ami jacques chirac iam year
jackpot et vous parlez vous parlez de un
petit peu de ma vie sexuelle puisque
j'ai vu pas mal de jeunes filles très
jolie dans les coulisses comme je disais
ray sa maman à madame nancy reagan
royaume speaking oui ouisme adam
strasbourg et gagnent
je disais bien sûr bien sûr je ne suis
pas un playboy il ya menottes lui mais
je veux faire l'amour quatre fois et
quel mec love to times non 4 c'est fort
pardon c'est même très très fort c'est
très très fort je suis épuisé cependant
je n'ai pas eu encore la chance de
tomber sur une nymphomane par contre
j'ai un ami qui n'est pas loin et il lui
a eu la chance de tomber sur une
nymphomane ça l'a épuisé car c'est un
poète il s'appelle francis cabrel c'est
[Applaudissements]
tapas encore semaine sur moi depuis midi
ça fait treize fois on a déjà fait tous
les tapis
la baignoire et la torre de nuit et ça
continue encore et encore c'est que des
cordes
[Musique]
hier déjà elle m'a démoli deux fois de
suite dans le taxi
la cancer je salue fait plus peur de
nous trouver ni tard à sarcelles les
saint quentinois et encore c'est que le
début d'accord
[Musique]
changer huit mois ce qui se passe
il fallait bien qu'un jour ça se casse
y'a plus rien de bach
[Musique]
uriel venue de taper par le moenner je
t'ai vu l'accident
recharge
vincent j'ai le plaisir qui veut démarre
le voilà à nouveau clouées sur le sol ou
sukumar mais c'est une folle et ça fait
marrer c'est trop
cette coque qui rit comme
l'avait pressenti l'auberge et ça
continue et encore c'est que le début
d'accord d'accord ça continue encore et
encore c'est que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'africain l'africain ce n'est pas le
titre de votre prochain film sur l'a5
c'est le surnom donné sur les pistes du
paris dakar à celui qui vous emmènera
tous les vendredis soirs à 22h30 à plus
de 200 à l'heure dans le monde des
sports mécaniques
hubert auriol
[Applaudissements]
alors hubert est rempli qu'est ce que ça
va être exactement grand prix ça va être
je pense une émission fantastique pour
tous les amateurs de sports mécaniques
avec bien sûr la formule 1 la formule
reine l'endurance les rallyes et surtout
et beaucoup la moto bien sûr avec les
grand prix de vitesse le cross sans
oublier un puncheur enfin je crois qu'on
peut dire que ça va être tout ce qui a
un moteur de l'essence et qui fait du
spectacle un grand spectacle donc avec
des sports mécaniques le vendredi soir à
22h30 grand prix présenté par hubert
auriol c'est notre futur rendez vous
voilà ça y est nous sommes arrivés au
samedi et le samedi sur l'a5 le mot de
passe c'est cinq sur cinq
[Musique]
et celui qui va vous révéler tous les
secrets de cette émission et chivu la
présentera bien sûr possède déjà tous
les atouts pour représenter les jeunes
c'est antoine verglas
alors une première question comme ça
qu'elles sont tes impressions pour cette
grande première de ça va tu vas rire je
l' ai posé la même question et je pense
que tout se passe bien pour vous aimez
ça va alors antoine cette émission 5 sur
5 donc le samedi à 19h30 qui va nous
raconter un petit peu de quoi il s'agit
et puis surtout j'aimerais que tu te
présente un petit peu qui est en toi de
là j'ai 24 ans je suis passé à une
musique et je vais donc animer une
émission comme tu l'as dit qu'ils
s'appellent cinq sur cinq cette émission
sera très sympa elle sera différente de
celle que vous pouvez voir actuellement
il y aura des invités des reportages des
infos des news et aussi nos coups de
coeur nos cinq étoiles alors tu n'es pas
venu les mains vides un petit cadeau ou
un léger sur vote de l'émission tout à
fait plus qu'un survol c'est même un
gros cadeau c'est un groupe que j'aime
beaucoup elle avait fait un tabac il y a
deux ans avec docteur mabuse elles
reviennent très très fort depuis
quelques mois avec machinerie c'est
propaganda mais avant de regarder
propaganda n'oubliez pas
samedi prochain 5 sur 5 19h30 sur
l'assassin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu
papa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
propaganda
et maintenant vous le savez vous avez
rendez-vous tous les samedis soirs à
19h30 avec antoine verglas pour 5 sur 5
l'émission pour les jeux mais le samedi
soir c'est également le jour du grand
show du samedi soir à 20h30 ce sera
cherchez la femme et la femme ne la
cherchez plus la voilà c'est amanda lear
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est le pas de cachet roger d'art
un mandat je suis furieux je trouve que
tu en as fait trop on attend des odeurs
au début de l'émission on a attendu très
longtemps tard voilà je joue les états
c'est bon jour là à leicester c'est que
le concorde était plein je suis venu en
wagon lit ça m'a pris très longtemps
j'ai fait des rencontres d'ailleurs et
j'arrive que maintenant tu vois là et je
ne suis pas une star juste une femme
d'ailleurs il fallait une femme dans
sept 7 ans équipe jusqu'à présent
vraiment faisait pas très gentil pour
elisabeth tordjman qui présente un talon
avec moi elisabeth tordjman c'est une
femme oui oui oui c'est une femme
charmante chacun sa croix moi on m'a
donné christian mora fait dire à
christian morin je sais ce que tu vas
dire assez dramatique on prend un
christian est un garçon charmant bien
élevé bon professionnel jeu à titouan
pas pourquoi tu peux tu sais pas ce qui
était sur toi au fond il est fou dont on
ne veut pas savoir il dit des horreurs
sur tout le monde et puis toujours en
retard pas difficile il veut toujours te
prendre la place arrêt
sur la couverture mais la tirent ils se
couvrent complètement vrai moi je
croyais alors on essaye de monter ce
spectacle ensemble nous aimons bien
modestement et il est gratuit qui se
fond dans cette série j'aurais tellement
aimé travailler avec toi tu vois pas ce
que la jolie
procès enfin christian qu'est ce que tu
fais oui attendre christian a pas
discuté avec antoine
va parler à ces gentilles team allemagne
et pour les bons retours et c'est très
bien rouge projette un ami me sens pas
seule en fuite une fois fait sentir
c'est toi je voulais enfin 51
non vraiment c'est toi c'est ton
partenaire ces gens qui vous avait parlé
un petit peu les missions durent
toujours ça alors c'est à 20h30 c'est
une émission d'entre eux ont cherché
femmes ça nous fait plaisir c'est un
petit peu ennuyeux pour un manga
effectivement fonda des sommes invités
puisque la première mission salon
recevoir serge gainsbourg eddy mitchell
et puis il faut vraiment bas thierry
lhermitte
alors amants des on explique un petit
peu la mécanique du jeu car il y a un
jeu avec à la clé un superbe collier
cartier tiens toi mais roger tenez vous
bien d'une valeur de 100 mille francs
c'est à dire 10 millions s'il est alors
il ya des épreuves de façon à éliminer
différentes candidates et doivent les
unes et les autres brillé par leur
talent leur action et c'est le public
qui choisit et voilà plus que ma
femme la drame idéal voilà l'idéal sur
l'aspect dieu sait que la femme idéale
c'est dur à trouver
et alors on passe à être contente la
mienne je te revient c on passe ainsi
que
[Applaudissements]
nous passons je tiens à le préciser si
vous n'en aviez déjà parlé on s'entend
très bien avec un monde ne joue plus
jamais seul avec des italiens
bon alors on langage oui c'est le samedi
soir même samedi soir il n'est même pas
question de regarder ce qui à l'autre
côté je nous sommes là 1 christian et
moi toutes les belles concurrentes le
collier et thierry lhermitte de temps en
temps donc le samedi soir à 20h30
cherchez la femme avec amanda lear et
christian morin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en fait c'était le fantastique show du
samedi soir cherchez la femme maintenant
je vais vous proposer une première sur
l'a5 la première grande rencontre
sportive entre deux grands champions
l'a5 d'un côté et de l'autre michel
platini
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pas mal l'accueil sur l'a51 cette
agréable et sympathique oui ça me change
un peu d'entrée du parc des princes avec
avec les finlandaises bat giresse mais
ça me change beaucoup disent oui mais
enfin je crois qu'il ya pas mal de gens
qui rêveraient de pouvoir un jour
rentrer au parc des princes à vos côtés
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez tout
ça de cette cinquième chaîne cinquième
chaîne bien qu à regarder aussi on
mélange avec le monde du football je
pense que s'ils avaient une coupe du
monde seriez dans les cinq premiers les
cinq premiers mois je reçois je pense
personnellement que tant qu'à faire on
gagnerait la coupe du monde et ça ferait
un petit peu comme l'italie en espagne
ou plutôt la france et d'europe 10
entrées sont français mais pourquoi pas
le michel vous savez vous savez dans
c'est vous ce que vous pouvez penser
j'en fais chanter chanter aussi et je
chante présidence voulaient danser
maintenant où vous avez préparé quelque
chose
essayer et réessayer non je vais vous
proposer un jeu un genre d'accord oui je
vous donner un nom et vous devrez me
répondre le titre d'une émission de la
scène de la grille de l'unss en fin de
compte fait la speakerine quoi voilà
vous êtes un vrai miers pickering de la
salle merci bon je vous donne le premier
nous maradona par exemple alors là il
est programme un leurre maradona
5 sur 5 5 sur 5 est pourquoi aujourd hui
devant le but qui fait tout ce qu'ils
veulent et fort il est bon à rien ça
c'est pas ma voix mais si je vous dis
barcelone barcelone barcelone barcelone
flamingo road flamingo parce que
flamingo barcelone flamenco parce que
vous allez essayer de faire danser
bouger un peu au prochain tour de la
coupe d'europe voilà voilà très bien
j'enchaîne avec henri michel henri
michel l'inspecteur derrick ah ouais là
et là pourquoi aujourd'hui dit rick
hughes poireau semaine mais pourquoi
d'eric d'eric parce que il va résoudre
tous nos problèmes en coupe du monde à
sa sauce une bonne idée mais même s'ils
jouent pas et je vais terminer en coupe
du monde et après j'espère parce qu'à
part sur un bo et puis bon c'est il faut
il penser ils peuvent en mettre un autre
on termine tient précisément avec
l'équipe de france au mexique l'équipe
de france au mexique voit superstar du
lundi à ces gens
[Applaudissements]
alors pour la première
de cinq je vous ai pris vous amener un
petit cadeau
[Applaudissements]
voilà nous sommes vraiment très touchés
c'est un maillot c'est de former un beau
numéro 10 c'est un numéro dix ans c'est
formidable maillot de michel platini ah
bah non là c'est ça aide
[Applaudissements]
non alors passer ça appartient soit
battiston soit bossis mais pas à platini
enfin mon avis il paraît que sur l'a5 on
multiplie tout par 2 à 1 bravo merci
messieurs merci beaucoup
c'était ce soit pour la première fois
sur l'a5 michel platini
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci à michel platini pour ce slogan
qui est également valable pour le sport
et le sport sur la 5 ce sera tous les
samedis soirs à 22h30 le grand show du
sport record et le grand show du sport
record sera présentée par guillaume
durand
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
guillaume il ya une question que nous
posons tous le grand show du sport
d'accord mais record qu'est ce que ça
veut dire je crois qu'il faut prendre un
seul exemple qui est l'exemple de la
première émission vous verrez samedi à
22h30 sur la 5 ce sera probablement un
des plus grands meetings d'athlétisme du
monde et on va vous donner par exemple
les participants d'un concours qu'on
connaît bien en france que la perche
vous avez qui n'ont français champions
olympiques sergei bubka soviétique rock
romane du monde s'y mette a que l'ombre
et les deux américains qui viennent de
battre récemment le record du monde en
salle à savoir bill et olsson et john
cryan je crois qu'il en soit c'est le
programme ce sera pareil dans absolument
toutes les disciplines y aura les
meilleurs du monde les soviétiques enfin
bref un show fantastique des images
fantastiques et un public américain qui
est un public fantastique puisque ce
sont les gens qui applaudissent
continuellement ses proches charléty
1500 personnes et 20 mille personnes
dans la salle les gens hurlent il n'y
aura pas que de la tête isme il y aura
de toutes les disciplines allant tout
n'allait dans négliger aucune allant
tout au long de l'année il y aura du
basket on jouera au foot il y aura du
golfe y aura du tennis je pense que le
programme sera complet il y aura du
sport
je dirais bistrot il y aura du sport un
peu snob il aura toutes les formes de
sports et je l'espère surtout des
surprises et des événements alors je
suis persuadé que ce sera bien d'autant
plus que guillaume durand je peux vous
le dire maintenant est un excellent
joueur de tennis puisqu'il a été deux
fois finaliste aux championnats de
france des journalistes et je crois que
ça mérite des applaudissements
nous allons accueillir maintenant un
homme qui est probablement le plus grand
danseur de tous les temps un homme qui a
le pouvoir de rendre facile des choses
les plus difficiles mesdames et
messieurs c'est avec beaucoup d'émotion
que je vous présente maintenant rudolf
noël
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
mais
e
et
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
mais
m
pas
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
elle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
compositeur
pis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez lu l'histoire de jesse james
[Musique]
je mente il vécu
tu es mort
ça vous
écoutez l'histoire
koné
à
[Musique]
petit à petit
les samples et danser
paulet
[Musique]
parker
lorsque j'ai connu clyde au ton toi
c'était un gars loyal
bollène et orange
c'est la société
[Musique]
m
jusqu'au pape a écrit sur elle et moi il
on prétend à connexion de 100 francs
[Musique]
/ g
chertsey un site qui suit
que l'est
[Musique]
chaque fois qu'un police man tu fais
pitié
[Musique]
je peux pas
la police
pas mystère
pas
[Musique]
parce que
maintenant chaque fois qu'on essaie de
se ranger
s'installer tranquillement
les trois jours
[Musique]
des mitraillettes
2 et 4 le tour
d'ensemble
[Musique]
que je tremble
m
[Musique]
toute façon il peut plus s'en sortir
la seule solution
c'était
sassus finir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sa présence sur la 5 ce soir est un
grand honneur ces musiques ont bercé le
monde entier michel legrand
[Applaudissements]
vous nous avez apporté deux cas d'opa
at-il vous êtes bien renseigné oui c'est
gentil non voilà j'ai écrit de la
musique de la chaîne donc que sont
l'ouverture et la fermeture de la 5 je
proposerai tous les dimanches soirs à
22h30
une émission de musique symphonique
musique classique avec les plus
prestigieux orchestres et chefs
d'orchestre du monde alors le titre de
l'émission l'a5 en concert et le premier
rendez vous ce sera quoi et bien
dimanche le premier concert sera dirigé
par un grand chef italien qui s'appelait
ricardo mutti
il y aura alors qu'istres de symphonique
philharmonique de la scala de milan
scala de milan endroits prestigieux et
mouthe il dirigera une oeuvre de rossini
une sonate en ré majeur et une symphonie
de jaén en do majeur voyez très beau
programme l'a5 en concert tous les
dimanches soirs à 22h30 avec michel
legrand
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sharma nicolas vernhes génisses les
jours heureux et la soirée heureuse sur
l'a5 une première soirée qui touche à sa
fin pas complètement ce qui suit est
très très bien aussi
[Applaudissements]
d'après les douces mélodies de richard
clayderman le rock agressif des spandau
ballet
[Musique]
à
sommet
[Musique]
non
pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
opus je suis
m
jusqu'à quand
là
[Musique]
ah ah
à
m
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
m
[Musique]
à temps avec un plus
à
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à 6
heures
[Musique]
voyons
et
oui
à
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oyonnax
[Applaudissements]
après ceux des invités je crois qu'on
peut dire voilà la 5 alors merci à tous
merci à tous les amis qui nous ont
soutenus jusqu'à maintenant merci à tous
ceux qui nous ont suivis merci à tous
les invités qui nous ont honoré de leur
présence et puis merci à vous tous qui
nous avaient suivi jusqu'à maintenant
[Applaudissements]
ça
les valets de l'a5
[Applaudissements]
low cost ont de la chance
et l'équipe de la salle
espérant vous avoir fait passer une très
bonne soirée nous en promettant encore
de meilleurs alors le rendez vous avec
l'a5 qu'il est pour demain pour après
demain et pour toujours là cinq aînés
vivent là cinq d'une chaîne nouvelle une
chaîne a mis pour demain et pour
toujours et vive la salle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]